my tool manager came back stage and he
was like you know you almost killed
someone today like literally it's like
blackouts
[Music]
let's do this I signed to Simon Cowell
because my manager at the time was like
it's a bigger check you're in a label
that is going to prioritize you because
you're not like anything on their label
this business comes around it and it
says we can turn this into money but
allowed someone else to tell me what my
next direction is
yeah everyone was like be a star have an
Entourage and who you're going to go out
with and I was like what do you mean oh
maybe sure Lloyd and I was like what
none of this [ __ ] means anything to me I
just was like I'm not enjoying this I
didn't ask myself what I wanted because
I was always accommodating what everyone
else wanted when did you realize that
something had to change well that's a
deep one though was that a place where I
couldn't actually talk to people because
I had social anxiety my manager was
being weird our relationship was
breaking down I had no confidence I felt
suppressed
I got like diagnosed with ADHD when I
read about what it's like I was like oh
[ __ ] it makes sense I can't even hold a
conversation with someone was it
prohibiting your life yeah 100 still
does today but I've learned to be aware
of it let's just do something just let
it go
Euphoria was the first time I felt
people actually heard the rarest form of
lab get into that point with true
freedom
what are your goals now the most
important thing in my career is to
before this episode starts I have a
small favor to ask from you two months
ago 74 of people that watch this channel
didn't subscribe we're now down to 69 my
goal is 50 so if you've ever liked any
of the videos we've posted if you like
this channel can you do me a quick favor
and hit the Subscribe button it helps
this channel more than you know and the
bigger the channel gets as you've seen
the bigger the guests get thank you and
enjoy this episode
[Music]
podcast has taught me one thing it's
that
we're all created
by and defined and shaped and molded by
our earliest context
so when you think about your earliest
context and how that shaped who you are
today and the person you went on to be
I'm talking about the like deep
characteristics you have the Deep
passions you have and all those things
that were nurtured in those earliest
years
what is your early context what do I
need to know about that context to
understand you
well that's a deep one now
um I
the first thing that comes to my mind is
church
um family was super religious
not always in the best way
um and not that I don't think there's
anything wrong with religion it just was
it was wrapped in a lot of things
um
that I don't always think is healthy but
um a lot of there was a lot of beauty as
well in terms of Music
worship and for me in worship was
work with energy like seeing somebody
connect with an energy or taking them
from their body with a sound or within
with a um
with Connection in a church like seeing
that happen like every Sunday can do
something to you and you kind of learn
from it
um so that was always beautiful and just
watching my family because that like I
don't know how this happened but just
everyone can sing or play an instrument
or they have some kind of musical talent
that was super inspiring to be around
um and then having a massive family as
well was I think
heavily shaped me because I always say
this to people about standing in the
middle of my house when I was I don't
know 10. I would have my sisters
upstairs singing like r b records my
brother downstairs with his friends
playing like Yellow Jackets jazz music
and like I don't know like um weather
report and then my other brother Cypher
in a room with his friends rapping and
um banging on an NPC drum machine and
like being in the middle of that was
like I want to do all of them
um
um and it was just mad like insanely
inspiring just to be around all of these
big personalities
um that even today when I make music I'm
like would would my sister like this
with my brother like this would my
family feel this
um where did that come from
that musical household who inspired that
parents grandparents it's weird because
on my mom's side I think it's the church
honestly because my mom and dad were
both in in the church
um and they both went to the same church
my Grandad was a reverend at um this uh
the church and his
uh my aunties and uncles used to sing
around uh and and like kind of do praise
and worship and and do like a circuit
around the country and that kind of
passed down to us um on my mother's side
and then on my dad's side he's a
guitarist he's uh well rest in peace
he's he was a guitarist he was a bass
player
um and his whole family were also in the
musical side of the church so be like my
mum and her family singing and my dad in
the kind of uh I'm playing with the
musician so it was just kind of like
always always it was always around when
I was a kid and I think music has been
like I guess like my the other sibling
that I didn't know was there you know
that um that was related to us and I
think um yeah I think it was between
Christianity and thing that was the
beginning to me because my house was
very very heavily boarded Around Church
everything like literally we couldn't
watch uh TV and if uh with about like uh
the TV being turned off when somebody
was kissing so like romance was like oh
whoa that's of the devil and then when I
went to school that's when the
it was like the Kaleidoscope went wild
and it was like oh [ __ ] all of this
stuff exists I really did feel like that
when I was a kid because it was so
sheltered going to Central London was
like going to another country to me like
that's how sheltered it was and it was
like home church and then everything
else around that was like I'm in a whole
other world so growing up for me was
just like discovering this other other
universe or other dimension if that
makes sense too yeah yeah what was your
what's your relationship like with your
mother and father
whoo
um
my mother was
um like I was saying the church
was beautiful but also toxic and my
mother was
um she kind of shunned from the church
because she had children out of wedlock
and um like I'm saying it's very heavily
guided and boarded so she was um she was
kind of
disowned by a lot of our family and
um she she had moved from North London
to Hackney and from then on I didn't I
don't think I saw my grandparents
for years like um after that like after
she was kind of put out one thing that
happens in Jamaica is because of a lot
of them came over here to the land of
milk and honey
um with race anything white was better
so my mom was one of the darkest of her
family and she grew up with um being
kind of very a lot of her life was very
short like it was like you're you're the
darker one of the family so
um don't don't shoot for the don't shoot
for the stars just just stay on the
ground you know
um and so because she was around a lot
of that energy when she was on her own
she kind of it's actually made a promise
to herself to not do that to her kids
and so growing up with my mom it was
very super supportive really
um she used to teach us my mom like I
was saying it was very sheltered around
uh I'm very religious she wasn't taught
because women were supposed to be in the
house women supposed to clean and doors
have a husband and your husband will go
and make the money and do all that stuff
around it so she she came out of this
kind of uh community and had
no understanding of taxes no
understanding how to keep a house no
understanding of a business not nothing
she didn't know anything and so she
literally had to learn from scratch and
would study psychology and study
transactional analysis and study
willpower and she would teach us and sit
us all around the table and be like what
is willpower and I remember I remember
like vividly like nine of us sitting
around the table and at the time we were
like Mom come on this is so boring why
do we have to do this but she would kind
of pull us into it and then we would end
up having these big conversations about
things that we just we never understood
or never got and she just wanted to make
sure she could give us something because
she had no money and she was just kind
of surviving she she nurtured our music
music she nurtured our creativity and
when she was coming up that wasn't
nurtured it was shut up sit down and
don't get in our way and that was her
upbringing it wasn't just my
grandparents that was very much common
and a lot of the parents of the 60s it
was just like children are to be seen
and not heard you know and don't don't
embarrass me in front of my friends that
was very much that and then with my dad
my dad was he was um very much abused
when he was a kid by
um his grandparent by by his stepfather
he was being a lot when he was a kid and
I think that affected him as a as a man
like as a father and he left home when
he was 15. so he wasn't there for me I
didn't see my dad when I was a kid
um but I I pity his beginning like
because I get why
he became who he became he was super
Musical and I think that was maybe the
most inspiring thing and that's the
thing I I got from him I always used to
see him playing his guitar when did he
leave your household
he left how old were you [ __ ] I don't
even remember that's that's how long ago
like I was young I was super young and I
think he came back well he must have
came back twice because my I have two
brothers and sisters younger than me so
um am I yeah he came um I think he left
I think he left on me
um and then my two sisters
um that are younger than me Rachel and
Jessica
um he came back around and they were
trying to like kind of um rekindle yeah
yeah do you not remember the household
changing in any way when when he left
I think I was too young like I was I was
really young so so when I grew up not
giving a [ __ ] that I didn't have a dad I
like if that makes sense I I didn't have
a connection with him I didn't
um I didn't know him that way a lot of
my older brothers and sisters were very
close and very like this is my guy this
is you know like my kids
are like I'm best friends with my kids I
love I like I'm I'm we have our own
private jokes we you know like like we
have that I never had that with my dad
so I didn't feel like anyone left I only
noticed how important he was when he
died like I was like oh [ __ ] you needed
that and like it was out it was a wall
you only got this towering point he was
when he died yeah honestly like honestly
before then I was just like oh it's just
a spoon sperm donor
like I don't really does it doesn't
matter to me it doesn't like it's like
it was and it wasn't even by my mom it
was just like I I didn't I wasn't
bothered about it you know
um but then when he died I was like I I
had kids then he hadn't met my my kids
and I remember my I was putting my
daughters to sleep and she had a bad
dream and I said
um I got you don't worry I'm here and I
was like [ __ ] I've never heard that and
I was like oh that's what like that's a
dad like if you get me like that's
that's how important that part of your
life is and then I was like also you
inherent things from your parents like
and that's not money that's not wealth
you do of course inherit those things
but I think the most important thing you
inherit from your parents is memories
even like mental health support like my
dad always said this like that sometimes
is like Petrol in your tank when you're
like
um I don't know how to get this business
off the ground I remember dad always
said this I remember Mom said don't
never give up like all that stuff like I
didn't grow up with that like if you get
I mean so
um that hit me when I when I was like my
dad's gone and and I understood how Like
Instrumental a parent could be in your
life when those um when those things are
around you know
um yeah so that's what I saw anyway but
but yeah that's really like my parents
in terms of how they affected me I often
like I think I figured myself out in
hindsight by almost by comparison of
like comparing me to my peers at a very
young age you kind of notice how you're
different from your peers yeah even from
your brothers and sisters I've got four
there's four of us in my family kids I'm
the youngest of four and much of how
I've understood myself is by realizing
what I'm not yeah you know what I mean
so when you think about like at that
young age under the age of 18 what who
are we figuring out that you were in
comparison to the the outside world even
with my brothers and sisters I remember
coming home with um Indie records and I
remember I was working with a girl and
she played me
Blondie and uh like like loads of loads
of like like kind of 70s 80s uh Indie
records I was like [ __ ] this is fun like
I always wanted to delve in things that
were foreign to me because I was like
okay I grew up with Grime I grew up with
hip-hop I get it but it was like where
what are these things I don't understand
and then when I would bring them home
I'd be like check this out and I'll be
like okay bro especially coming from the
background of that gospel and
um like kind of like you know black
music
um um it was weird to come home with
music that that was so foreign you know
and so nobody even knew how to
compliment me on it but go like you're
doing your thing I guess like you know
and and I feel like I've seen that
happen uh consistently in my life where
I grew up around Grime group around
Grime artists I went to Grime Raves but
I never wanted to make Grime and I never
felt like I was
um the kind of black guy that I was
supposed to be when I was in those
environments I was like I was always
weird or like I never knew all the
dances I used to dance funky and like I
was just I just knew like I don't know
if I'm supposed to be here if I had 16
year olds you yeah 16 16 year old weird
as hell just just I remember my
girlfriend told me about how when she
met my wife now but when she was my
girlfriend she was like I remember
seeing you years ago
and
um uh you would wear a durag I would be
wearing like a um you know those capes
like Marilyn Manson came like it was
like [ __ ] black glass jet like long
ass jacket I would have like a you know
those metal Fingers um yeah yeah tube
yeah yeah yeah let's have a night finger
on and it had like a crucifix on it and
it was crazy I don't know why I was
wearing it but I wore it and then I had
like a Dunlop cap like backwards and
then I would be wearing Dunlop trainers
and I was just I was just a weird kid
and I would I would always dress
in the most funkiest ways ever and my
wife was like it was just so funny you
just didn't give a [ __ ] and I didn't
even notice I was doing it I just was
like well this is stuff I'm gonna wear
but most I remember being you know I was
like 14. all I wanted to do was fit in
so all I wanted to do was like wear the
outfits that everyone else was wearing
and just fit into the crowd and be
accepted by the crowd so you sound
slightly different I couldn't I even if
I wanted to wear what everyone was
wearing I couldn't I didn't have the
money so it was like what was cool with
my family or where our call was was that
we were creative and so we found our way
of being uh popular or being um uh kind
of loved amongst our peers by our like
character and our personality if you get
I mean that was your whole family yeah
all them dancers singers we would dance
together we used to put on we we done a
show in school together as a family and
put on like a concert and we had the
whole school come and pay to watch us
perform so we were kind of like little
superstars in our neighborhood like if
you get I mean as a group so I remember
used to write articles on us the Jackson
9 and all this stuff like so it was like
we were very like like kind of my family
was really loved for just their
creativity we never had the money to be
those cool kids like somehow we like
kind of um transcended uh the physical
cool like the physical side of cool
because we definitely didn't have that
stuff interesting
do you know who was driving that in your
so you've said like the outside world
responded well to it and they kind of
embraced it and said yeah but was there
someone was there someone at home
driving individuality in your in your
house or was it just the fact I think
it's my mom honestly and it wasn't my
mom this is my mom didn't get in the way
of it and I think that's one thing if
when I'm talking about things that you
inherit from your parents I could
definitely say I inherited that
inherited that from my and my my mom is
that she didn't get in the way of us
being ourselves
um and if anything she would laugh at it
or be like go do you like
um
um so like I remember yeah I remembered
vividly like that being just my mom
being open and kind of seeing my my
older brother Jamie was a producer and a
DJ and he used to make his own sound
systems because he got inspired by um
you know like dub basically you know
like dub but at the time everyone was
making like jungle but it was all it all
came from the scar dub world if you get
I mean and so he used to make I used to
help him make his speakers for his DJ
sets and then he would go out into like
the festivals or not in hill and put on
his own DJ set with his friends and so
yeah yeah like that all of this stuff
was going on like side by side while I
was a kid you know sounds like a like a
really a nice form of like creative
chaos
chaotic though
when did you start focusing on music
what age
it's just kind of like I've guessed in
school I had a band called Dynamics and
one of the guys that was in it um you
might not have his flow he's a sick
producer he's done little Sims out he's
done so many cool albums like most of
the stuff that everyone's loving right
now he's kind of had a hand in
um and um we had a band in school in
stock Newington yeah that would that
would Inspire that would inspire a lot
of stuff like um we were making our own
music we were like we're gonna be the
biggest band in the world we used to
argue all the time like we were like
like flipping Rolling Stones we thought
we were like like rock stars and in our
school we would give up flyers and make
our own Flyers um and like stick them up
around the school like come to our
concert and all this stuff so we were
just very very like brashy and like we
got this what age was this this was like
well started popping 14. so you leave
secondary school at like 16 years old
right yeah
at that point what's your orientation in
life if I'd asked you what what you're
going to be when you grow grow up what
would you have told me at 16 upon
leaving school everyone knew I was going
to be a musician Everyone by that point
literally like I remember leaving like
we had that in my classroom in school
they were like everyone wrote down who
do you think is going to be the most
successful who do you think is going to
be rich first who thinks this and they
were this like lab and like Tim Tim and
I was like I didn't even believe I was
like okay cool I I know I want to do
these things but like I was super mega
focused I used to get in mad trouble
just so I could go to the music room so
literally like my whole existence has
been like I want to write records I want
to write records and like that's all I
do
I was on a mission to write records
and that what age did that start because
I know when it it started to when you
got signed and when you released your
debut album and stuff but I'm trying to
understand how long you'll like Mastery
process was from the first time you
picked up an instrument or wrapped or
sang or wrote but it's weird because of
that my brother Josh
um amazing drama McNasty
bad boy drummer he taught me how to play
the bass taught me how to play the drums
and I would see him doing that so I'll
just copied my older brother but because
I have so many
then I'll go to Jamie's room and Jamie
would teach me how to use the MPC so I
would go to his studio and him and his
boys would be smoking drinking
um and like on a Madness and I I would
like he kind of took me under his wing
for a bit and I would like go around
with him to like in his world which was
very much more like it was much more
like hip-hop Urban so you've got this
full kind of kind of gritty like more
hip-hop like we were listening to Pete
Rock Wu-Tang all that [ __ ] and then my
other brother who was more music like a
bit more like like instrument drums uh
and I would be around his friends that
were musicians you know so we spoke to
someone on your team and they said that
we could put any instrument in front of
you and you'd play it
and this kind of like I now I kind of
understand where that came from yeah
yeah it's just like
everything's an instrument to me
honestly everything
like this table yep the sound of your
voice is a tone like uh like I I I can
just hear music all the time like it
doesn't stop
um and I might be I don't know might be
like I um I got like diagnosed with ADHD
because I thought I may have had it and
um so I went to go check and I was like
when I read about what it's like I was
like oh [ __ ]
um it makes sense why I'm so that's
literally this is all I do my life is
that I raise my children I make music
that's literally been my life you got
diagnosed with ADHD yeah
it's funny because I was sat here
recently yeah with uh with an expert on
the topic so it's very front of mind the
topic of ADHD yeah
um and one of the things he said was
that you know there's been this rise in
ADHD now yeah in in
did the world specifically in Western
countries I'm only saying specifically
because I know the stats where I think
it's 30 years ago
one in 20 kids had ADHD now it's one in
nine
um and his take on it was that ADHD is
an early response
basically when we were young and there
was stress in our in our households
the the child when the stressful event
learns how to basically turn off their
attention as a way to protect themselves
yeah like switch their attention away
from that thing so and they've looked at
all these studies and it really inspired
by them where they get 65 000 65 000
parents and the parents who have the
most stress in their lives end up having
kids with ADHD yeah makes sense and it's
just interesting so it's just front of
my thoughts you know so it goes back to
a childhood but yeah it sounds mad
stressful yeah it's not it's not far off
like in terms but yeah um it even
talking about sometimes sounds silly
because everyone thinks they have ADHD
um and everyone says it so I I was like
I I hate kind of
I know I hates a strong word but like
talking about ADHD I don't enjoy trying
to victimize myself with it
um and that's why I checked because I
was like I think it's disrespectful for
a person with
um something that affects their mental
health or something that affects them uh
their ability to to do what they want to
do or like to just live a life that is
supposed to be I don't know what is
normal but yeah you know
um and that prohibits them
um and I think it's disrespectful to be
like Oh I'm autistic I'm this um without
really like kind of knowing
um how is it prohibiting your life yeah
100 still does today what's the what's
this what's the symptom or what's the
can't finish [ __ ]
[Music]
um
forget like like literally it's like
blackouts it's like oh
um even in conversation sometimes when
people say something to me it would be
like I've taken the information it just
kind of dies away and I'm like [ __ ] I
can't even hold a conversation with
someone or
keeping up relationships remembering to
get back to people
um and that in business in terms of
networking and and I'm not talking about
networking from a
um using people like I'm not ladder
chasing but there is a part of it where
it's like yeah your your life's your
business is not going to change if you
don't respond and so like I would I
would work with artists and it would be
like lab you're so sick I love your [ __ ]
yeah please like can can you write my
album I'll be like yeah and then start
the record and they'll be like they
haven't heard from me where's lab why is
he he just he just clocks out you know
and it's like I'll just forget I'm doing
it and I'll get dragged into something
else I wonder if there's a relationship
between ADHD and uh creativity because
you know I hear a very similar thing
from pretty much all of the artists that
I've sat here with about
about and what you've what you've just
described there
going back to the this this uh all these
instruments you can play and all these
brothers and sisters that are playing a
different variety of um instrument and
learning different sort of art forms as
it relates to like creativity
um how important do you think it has
been for your creativity and the art
that you've created in your career to
have all of these I remember one one
person I spoke to talked about
creativity is being like all of these
different clouds in your mind and then
sometimes the clouds hit each other and
that's like a new idea yeah yeah but in
order to be creative you have to have as
many clouds as possible
I I feel that um
I think that's in learning like this
like
um being able to create Variety in your
ability to
um transmit
um
like an idea because I always look at I
don't I look at creativity as
um articulate in your soul
and that that's the true form for me
like because you can be creative but not
really tell the truth while you're being
creative like you're just like oh I I'm
making something that I think people
will like
um and that there's and you can still be
creative while doing that where it's
like okay cool here's something that I
know people are going to respond to I'm
going to get a reaction out of you and
then there's the other side where I
think
to me I believe is Arts where you're
transmitting and you're articulating the
sound or the frequency of your soul to a
person and I feel like every soul has a
song even even if it's not in music like
every soul
um has a uh a direction or a place it
wants to go and it has purpose and it's
like I I can and I I always ask artists
I'm like what'd you hear in you like not
what do you hear outside of you and oh
um what's it burning boys doing this and
that guy's doing this and if I mix these
together then it maybe makes me and it's
like no no
what's in you what do you hear like
right here like just internally and so
um for me I had to do that to to find
um what I wanted to say and and I'm
still finding that I'm still kind of
like um I I guess it's learning how to
like uh be unafraid
to be like totally naked because bearing
your soul is naked like it's like
it's like if I do this someone's gonna
be like this is [ __ ] and it's gonna hurt
if you're on the process of learning to
be unafraid was there a time that you
were taught to be afraid
um my whole life like everything I'm
still afraid now but but I can see it
and I think that makes a difference
um in terms of
um whoever I choose to be afraid but
before I had no choice I was just like I
don't even know what this is I just was
like I'm not enjoying this I wasn't
enjoying my career so I was like I'm not
enjoying why am I not enjoying this and
then I was like okay I'm not saying what
I want to say I'm not saying what what I
feel like saying or what I feel excited
about saying and I feel like my world is
being governed by
um accommodating my periphery like my
manager says if you do this this is
going to gain a reaction and it's kind
of like your inner child says oh I want
somebody to say he's cute I want someone
to say he's worthy and so you run
towards that energy like and and I
always always saying
um in the music industry it's like a
bunch of kids trying to get a pat on the
back that's what we're all doing and
it's like if you see in your a r or you
see it in your peers and everybody's
trying to get that pat on the back like
well done good boy and everybody wants
to get the good boy and so we're all
running after good boy but when you
finally realize that I don't give a [ __ ]
about your good boy I don't want it I
want I want a good boy from myself I
wanna I wanna be like you said it like
you actually said what was internally
going on and I
um does it matter what people
um uh say on the other side like and get
into that point where you're like
um
I am comfortable with what I will
receive after I've said what I said
um from my soul I think for me is like
true freedom is like okay cool I'm gonna
say what I need to say
that's a journey right yo that's just
scary man that's a journey so you start
you know you start out in your career
yeah you're trying to trying to get on
you're learning the ropes people are
telling you giving you advice you don't
know better so you follow the advice
Church boy in in the music industry
sometimes the advice pays off so you go
okay I'm gonna listen to you more yeah
yeah and then at some point that's the
worst part is when it pays off then you
go then yeah because you think it works
you're like well I I did everything I
didn't want to do but it worked so maybe
I should do more of this and then what
are you referring to a million just like
records or like what what part of your
career is this though
I think uh
okay so like with Simon Cowell and uh
when I signed to Simon Cowell I signed
to Simon Cowell because my manager at
the time was like
it's a bigger check
you're in a label that
um isn't gonna know uh is it isn't is
going to prioritize you because you're
not like anything on their label I was
like yeah great idea but I didn't think
about it for myself I allowed someone
else to tell me what my next direction
is because
um I did I don't think I had the
strength at the time to even think about
what I wanted for myself if you get me
same way I owned a restaurant
uh that was my manager I look was like
you should own a restaurant I was like
yeah they sold a restaurant and then I
was like I don't know [ __ ] about a
restaurant I've never cared about a
restaurant and and I only realized that
later but it kind of felt like you're
supposed to look like a mogul and you're
supposed to look important and you're
supposed to gather all these things that
that that start to create
um oh I'm hearing Keeping Up Appearances
that's what it is yeah what I was
hearing from that it's like because you
didn't
I was going to say because you didn't
know what you wanted someone else told
you what you wanted but it's more like
part of it sounded like you didn't have
the conviction to stand up for what you
wanted no you did that's what it is I I
didn't ask myself what I wanted I never
did because I was always accommodating
what everyone else wanted and I still do
it now sometimes but but I've learned to
to be aware of it is that because is
that in part because of like when we're
coming up we're a little bit desperate
just to get on that we just
we don't have the power yet to say like
I want to do it my way because we're
still trying we still need to check or
because we still think one thing I love
about the ADHD is
I don't think about money the same way
most people do so
like a lot of my peers in the music
industry they're building a business
because they can like they're they're
going okay this yeah we're gonna do this
and that's gonna come with that and they
carved this whole internal plan and I'm
like my plan is like if I can take a
sound out of heaven and put it on a
[ __ ] computer that is mad to me like
that that is like that literally lights
up my whole soul and I feel so excited
literally sometimes when I make a music
I cry because I'm like it hit me that
hard if you got me and so like that for
me is like it literally like I would
live for that that's enough for me but
then then around that like taking
Stardust from the clouds or from
wherever you want from the Universe
um this business comes around it and it
says we can turn this into money but you
have to do this with it and then you've
got a funnel it and you can you can only
do this in order to get that and you're
like oh [ __ ] okay cool be a star what
does the star look like oh
um be in a car with flipping tinted
windows having Entourage and going like
you're the [ __ ] okay cool cool I don't
really know how to do that I'm kind of
really a geek like because that's what I
was when I was 16 and then before you
know it you're like I don't know none of
this [ __ ] means anything to me and I
felt like I was being out that's the
time I think when you're talking about
this place where I don't believe I
belong I was in the music industry and
like I was around I remember like in
cycle they went who are you going out
with like when I was first signed it was
like Who you gonna go out with and I was
like what do you mean it was like oh
maybe sure Lloyd and I was like what I
was like what do you mean and then I'm
gonna send you to this party JLS are
there
um you just gotta like there's gonna be
photographers outside the building
um um be ready to be like thing because
we're trying to put you around this
facade so I was like oh [ __ ] this is
this is how it works and I guess and and
so being around found that that was
instantly like
I I thought studying music theory and
studying modes and scales was was your
like uh what made you worthy of being in
this industry if you got me um but it
became like no entertainment isn't Croft
entertainment is entertainment and
people will be entertained by anything
so play the game yeah and and so it was
like find your way like just try and try
and lie as long as you can when did you
feel when did you feel the symptoms of
that so I sit here I've seen it with a
lot of people who did did a very similar
thing and they say I spent a decade like
wearing the mask and like wearing the
outfit yeah and then at some point you
know I remember phone cotton saying like
she's driving to work and she just
starts having panic attacks yeah she
thinks [ __ ] this same I'm going to my
happy place and she launches this brand
called happy place where she gets to
control her and Destiny and be herself
she doesn't have to do the like oh yeah
I'm fine you know she can be the full
expression that's a hard one bro yeah
and it's funny yeah we all meet each
other yeah and and that's is what all
the same boy or girl waiting to get the
part on the back good boy good good girl
and then and then uh I feel like we meet
each other and we're all pretending that
we've we've got it together so I could
have seen fun and she's like I'm dying
inside right now but she has to be fun I
work together I'm like [ __ ] she's quite
so well together so I was like man I'm
I'm lying like they they could see it
like I'm a fake I'm a fake and
everyone's doing that but it's weird
like and then it turns you into this
person that's like getting kicks out of
lying better than the other like so you
go to an award ceremony and it's like we
sold 50 million or about I don't know
five million records this week how many
did you sell and it's like I'm I'm
valuable you stop yeah people believe in
my liar now I believe in it and it's
like uh like it starts to create this
thing in you where um if it becomes
successful like we were saying it's like
if it if it works and it pays off then
you're like oh I need to I need to like
I need to be this guy now I've got I've
got to believe in this guy and so yeah
it's so funny like when you're saying
we're fun I'm like I would have never
known I would have never known that that
stuff was going on because I feel like I
felt like she had it well together and I
was like I was having panic attacks what
were the symptoms then for you when did
you realize that something had to change
I was smashing guitars on stage
and I know rock stars do that I was a
church boy so it was that was big for me
um and I One show I was performing and I
was like I hate this but I was saying I
hate this but I wasn't saying it in my
mind I was like
uh I could feel it I was like why am I
I'm in this front of this crowd there's
not even an audience I wanted to be in
front of what am I doing they're loving
it but but I'm still just like what is
this and
um my band when I was talking about
accommodating my band's eating my um
brighter before I get into my room
because I was accommodating everyone to
the point where it was like like me
please like I'll do whatever I can to
make sure you're comfortable in my space
even if it means giving you all my space
so my band was eating out my radar my
some of the people on my um Team were
taking my uh like stuff from my um like
they would you know like Brands when
Brands give you stuff they would take it
and give it to their families nothing
was given to my family and my misses had
actually noticed this
um and I was like no no I was always
making excuses for for everyone that was
doing what they were doing how does that
come from in you that people pleasing
trying to trying to think it must be my
dad it might it must be like that my dad
because I think I've silenced my dad's
absence in me so it was just ah sperm
donor don't worry and I had to I had
this thing in my head where it's like I
don't need this guy but it's like
um I think uh him not being present is
like what do I need to be for you to be
here if you get me and I think
um
that happened and also I think the music
industry helped create some of that as
well where it was like because before
the music industry I was that guy I'm
from I do rag one I think I looked wonky
as hell bro it was I look back at some
of the pictures and I'm dying I'm like
who is this guy but but I was confident
enough to walk around London looking
like this like hodgeboge guy and super
cool yeah because I think the music
industry was like you need to be this
and I was like whoa how in order to be
accepted yes from a young age you'd like
that like
I guess at some stage you felt not
accepted by your father is that what
you're saying I think that's where that
came from yeah I think there's an
element of that yeah yeah I think that
church as well was there and where it
was like there was a way to behave there
was a way of being wrong there was a way
to be to to be loved if you behaved this
way this is what you get you know like
um God loves you yeah God God loves you
if you behave like this interesting and
that's not true really intrigued by the
idea of like how how we become people
Pleasers because and it typically even
from from speaking to Gabor who
literally wrote a book about this
um he says the same thing in those early
years when you know we were seeking the
acceptance or validation from a parent
and we're struggling to get it we have
that battle with them of trying to
trying to prove that we're good enough
so that becomes our adult tendency to
seek approval and seek trying to you
know fit into others expectations you
become an artist that becomes really
prevalent in your in your life in your
music to the point that you're on stage
performing music that it sounds like
yeah what is this
this yeah do you know what so many of us
so many if we if we Act
it inauthentically for a lot enough time
we build a life around that authenticity
build a friendship group around it we
build a in your case a fan base around
it and I dropped it I was like no
loudest and then the pain of keeping up
with that expectation and that
that Community built around you that
doesn't resonate with who you truly are
that's when the you know panic attacks
and the the psychology kicks in and
tries to save you but I think I've
spoken to a lot of ice but as well
everyone thinks that by doing you you're
still gonna achieve that same success
and that's the scary thing I think for a
lot of people where they're like I found
myself now I'm gonna make the album that
I own the piece of craft or work or
thing that that people um that that
means everything to me and it's like no
it's entertainment people don't give a
[ __ ] like you did it for you just do it
for you and it's like you have to know
that some people may resonate with the
true you or you might have to go and do
work and build a new audience and and
it's going to take the same amount of
time but people don't want that like
when they're like I'm gonna be me and
it's like yeah uh you've got 10 views on
this one yeah oh [ __ ]
there is some kind of Truth to the yeah
game that's the reality that's the
reality of it I had to learn that as
well it's like
um being you is for you and you have to
do it for you and you also have to
accept the consequences of of being you
um and even the consequences of the way
you do business as well like I I don't
wanna I don't want to talk all around
the world saying hello to every and
every person not really connecting with
the people I'm I'm meeting I'm just like
oh I'm famous just kiss my ass and I'm
gonna move over to the next country and
do the same like I don't want to do that
I don't it doesn't excite me and it
drains my energy it drains my Creative
Energy but if you don't tour
if you're getting a million for every
show well you're getting a I don't know
half a meal for every show you're like
whoa maybe I wouldn't say no to that do
I wanna do I wanna go do that and it's
like but then if I go the true me that
my Center says no
okay no I'm not gonna do that well then
don't cry by after and and a lot of us
do where it's like I made this decision
a lot of us can do that you know but
learning to like really accept your
choices and live and die by them
um Can can help you find fulfillment and
that to me is like money that's that's
that's like you have this gradual
feeling building from the sound of it
and then is that day on stage was that
the the turning point for you was that
yeah I threw a guitar in the air I
almost hit a camera woman why did you
throw it I was pissed I was I I was
backstage something happened my manager
was being weird our relationship was
breaking down
um and I I I had a dependency it was
intense I had no confidence I literally
I was at a place where I couldn't
actually talk to people because I was I
had um social anxiety and and so he was
super confident and outgoing and
um kind of like was like a someone to
lean on and that kind of went up to my
my early days in my career and so
um our relationship started to break
down and it felt like if I didn't have
him saying my music's good it wasn't
um and and I kind of looked for it to
him for that like like a father figure
yeah yeah yes exactly that like I I kind
of saw him as a father figure and we we
had a really close relationship and then
it just started to break down when money
started coming in and
um I felt that happening but I didn't
know what was going on internally I was
just like something's weird this is just
messed up and then I went on stage threw
this guitar in the air this cameraman
was there and I remember there was a fan
in the crowd because I'm a people
pleaser but also it pisses me off I was
watching the crowd and there was this
one guy and he was looking at me and he
was like it was just like he was just
saying [ __ ] like you look like an
idiot and I was like I believe you ah
then I just threw this guitar man and it
almost hit this woman and I didn't see
it and my tour manager came back stage
and he was like you know you almost
killed someone today and I was like wait
a minute
because some guy in the crowd was giving
you a funny look him and the thing that
all this stuff was going on stage I know
and then I was like what the [ __ ] am I
doing here like cool
and then I threw this guitar in the air
because I was just like [ __ ] this place
and then
it literally just was like
and and just nearly just skimmed her and
and I and when he said that I was like
whoa I was like the sun's going on I
need to deal with it did you have an
anger problem a man a mad angle problem
but that's ADHD as well but mad anger
for issues like like from primary school
I I don't I don't really haven't seen
that guy for a very long time but it's
crazy because it reminds me again of the
thing you know gabble was here like five
hours ago he's literally written a book
on this that's why all these topics are
so friend of mine yeah yeah and what he
was talking about is there's there's
such thing as healthy anger where
um which is actually a cure something
that allows us to heal because he says
that when we have like chaotic
upbringings and we you know have
abandonment from a parent etc etc we it
creates this kind of like internal anger
and resentment yeah but at the same time
it creates people pleasing yes and
suppression
so the anger becomes suppressed and it
looks like people pleasing on the
surface
yeah those layers yeah yeah and that's
what there was a lot of that where it's
like
um you can be passive aggressive and
it's I I feel like it sounds like a
contradiction to be a people pleaser but
then to have
the volcano can erupt yeah yeah I know I
know it sounds like but it makes sense
you're suppressing so much stuff and
you're not saying that and that's what
the big thing is in music I was also I
felt suppressed so it was like can I go
can I find can I stop suppressing that
as well because I was doing it musically
where I was in I was in this kind of Pop
realm and I was like no but I want them
to hear all the layers of me and I think
Euphoria was the like first time I felt
people actually heard what was going on
on my hard drive for real for real and
and then with it connecting I was like
oh it was like oh they get it like but
but I was like it took so long for me to
be able to try and share it and it took
for somebody else to go give me your
hard drive I'm gonna put this all in my
I'm gonna put all of this stuff in my
show and I want you to make new stuff in
my show for them for me to not suppress
it because I it was like I'm gonna do it
for you
quick word from one of our sponsors I've
got a tip for all of you that will make
your virtual meeting experiences I think
10 times better as some of you may know
by now Blue Jeans by Verizon offers
seamless high quality video conferencing
but the reason why I use blue jeans
versus other video conferencing tools is
because of immersion their tools make
you feel more connected to the employees
or customers you're trying to engage
with and now they're launching one of
their biggest feature enhancements to
impact virtual events so far called Blue
Jean Studio I actually used it the other
day I did a virtual event using the
studio which I think about 700 of you
came to TV level production quality all
done by one person with very little
technical experience on a laptop so if
you've got an event coming up and you're
thinking about doing it virtually check
out blue jean studio now let me know
what you think because I genuinely
believe I know this is an advert and I'm
supposed to say this but I genuinely
believe it's the best tool I've seen for
doing really immersive simple but high
quality production virtual events quick
one right now one of my sponsors on this
podcast who I absolutely adore crafted
the men's jewelry brand are having a
sale right now up to 70 off a brand
that's already incredibly affordable if
you ever see me wearing jewelry on
videos in real life it's crafted jewelry
this particular piece
these pearls here are one of my favorite
pieces to wear when I'm trying to wear a
fashionable item all of their pieces I
wear all of their rings I wear all of
their jewelry and I did before they
sponsor this podcast I actually asked
them to sponsor this podcast because I
was such a big fan of the brand I'm not
somebody that rolls around in Rolexes
and stuff like that but I do want
quality jewelry that isn't going to
change color that is going to be durable
enough to keep up with me that looks
fashionable and that has a sense of
meaning and that's exactly what crafted
has in their rings in their necklaces in
everything they produce I know the
founders I know how much they care and
if you're a man that often struggles to
find a good place to to buy good quality
jewelry that's not going to change color
that's not going to break
crafted is the answer and it's
incredibly incredibly affordable and
they have a sale on right now which they
never ever do 70 off I implore you to go
and check it out you mentioned panic
attacks yeah yeah something fun told me
about from her Lost Hair everything lost
her yeah like I had clumps of hair
falling out it was mad like it was like
I got to do it and my wife was a big
like part of supporting that because she
um yeah she just was like she could see
it all happening
um
and
funny enough I couldn't fight for her at
the time as well like um like she could
see it all happen and she was like this
is not the way business should be done
shouldn't be treated this way and and a
lot of the people that were around me uh
made her like the monster she became the
and she was one of the boundaries yes
that's right and so you know like um
have you ever seen spinal tap no no okay
but I I kind of I call it the spinal tap
moment where the Mrs becomes a manager
and she wasn't managing me she wasn't
even trying to she hates the music
industry but she wanted to be like I
want to protect this guy's sanity and
everyone else around me was like we've
got a gig flipping a hundred and
something Grand what do you mean like
why is why are you not going to do the
show and it's like yeah yeah no I know
you're feeling tired you're feeling
you're are you feeling a bit
emotional okay okay don't worry man
don't worry like look at what he's doing
he's doing all this work and uh
comparisons and all this stuff and so
there was a lot of manipulation and she
was seeing it and I think they kind of
didn't like
um that so she got she got intensely
like kind of um protective yeah yeah but
also then she became Lamar like the she
became the there was a Witch Hunt and it
kind of felt like it was directed at her
and I wasn't strong enough to support
her in that time if you get I mean like
I was I was still too you were taking
the wrong I was accommodating no I
wasn't even taking the sides it was just
no no it's it's because of this and okay
so you would just like okay I'm supposed
to have it together but I don't have it
together but like no I don't think they
meant that and and I didn't hear the
stuff that was going on but when I heard
what was going on I was like oh [ __ ]
this is crazy
um have you ever spoke to her about that
yeah yeah that's what built strength in
our relationship was that I said I said
to apologize to her and I I think a lot
of people don't notice how strong and
powerful women are beside people that
are in the public eye or like in the
music industry or entertainment industry
it's like some of them some of them are
like of course wonky or whatever but and
are there for the wrong reasons but the
ones that are there for the right
reasons sometimes get
um
they're kind of yeah they they don't get
treated very well if you get them
because it's like you're the guy you're
the person with the guy yeah yeah and
it's always that it's like you're the
person with a guy like um and so she
um she just was like mad supportive and
she introduced me to a shrink
um and got me like like a lot of support
like just to talk to someone and the
life coach because she worked around
psychology she was just really like um
she put me on to a lot of things that um
I wouldn't have had if she wasn't around
you know so it was like super important
to have her women in that that feminine
they call it like the feminine energy
yeah it's so
that particular feminine energy is so
lost upon men these days yeah we talked
about it earlier with this whole idea of
like be more of a man and yeah and don't
express your emotions and be a tough guy
and all this stuff but then you look at
the stats around mental health and
suicide and you see that it's just not
working for me yeah yeah over
masculinity is just not clearly not
working yeah women and including in my
life yeah have an ability to to open us
up to the other side yeah which is
unbelievably healing she's mad she's
just super smart and like um
I just think she was more aware she she
had like uh
she had this thought that was pretty
intense and so it woke her up to a lot
of things that I didn't I wasn't aware
of and so she kind of schooled me on a
lot of things that I think if she wasn't
around I would have lost it I would have
been like it would have been like
where's lab and then it would have been
like oh right he's on YouTube with like
no teeth shouting at the camera I don't
know like some you know how people go
like way left but yeah like I think if
she wasn't around I wouldn't be around
honestly when you look back on the art
that you created in that time in that
phase of your life the music the hits
pass out frisky that you know all of
that music you created
how do you feel about the music now
so if you walked in here and it was
playing how would you like how would you
think
um I laughed now I'm like oh that's
Vibes that's fun like it's kind of like
it's fun
um and sometimes I see the Brilliance
and I'm like like past that still hits
me and I'm like I can see the energy and
it was the moment where I kind of pulled
up my sleeves and I was like I'm not
doing this [ __ ] anymore I'm not gonna
fake it I'm gonna make something I wanna
hear and and then it paid off but I have
moments like that and then I get scared
again like it's like pass out yeah and
it and it takes me a lot to get there
where I'm like I'm gonna do something
good and it's like everyone's like Well
Done do more and I'm like I'm just
kidding like that can happen when I'll
get too shocked
um it's just dealing with yourself it's
being um being aware of yourself like
what I was saying to be conscious of
yourself
I'm aware of your behavior helps you
create peace in your life like and and
make choices in a moment that are gonna
um
support you in more ways than one if you
um more than just Financial yeah and
finance just becomes such a big thing in
this industry even status and finance
being a father Finance is like you run
you run for it because you're taught
that's the way a man's supposed to be
um why did you go to eventually you go
to La at what 24 years old or something
why did I go to La yeah was it 24 years
old you you yeah yeah you left the UK I
wanted to go to LA to get away from the
UK I'm not even just get away I think
that was going on internally like I was
like I need to do something different
um but this was after you released your
first album yeah and I was getting I was
taking it took me like ages to do a
second and I was like I don't know I was
just in my head about it and so I went
to LA to go and just just be somewhere
different try working with some other
writers and like maybe uh kind of get
new fresh energy you know I was getting
in my head about it yeah you're that
second album So You released the first
album on psycho I always call it the
difficult second album that's what they
call it second up because it's like you
had a moment and then it's like oh I've
got to do that again it's like and that
was on accident and it was always on
accident it's like nothing
um like you can paint anything by
numbers but you you can never even in
business you can't recreate exactly the
same thing unless it was supposed to
happen because the world's changed yeah
that's it yes so it's like yeah like
well even in this industry now like um
me and my team have been talking about
it but it's like we're in a whole new
world
most records are sold online like
heavily like Tick Tock like Tick Tock
that's it that's that's how you sell
records and so to come into that and go
how do I find myself amongst this
without losing
um my authenticity
um
uh what do you do like you know like and
and so then it kind of goes back to a
lot of the things that have happened
where it's like don't be that guy don't
don't be that guy and just like keep up
appearances
um Find Your Way find a way of saying it
in a way that means something to you you
know I'm really you said because I sat
with Louis Capaldi and he said to me I'm
[ __ ] it he's his second album's
coming out yeah he's like I'm [ __ ]
it and he told me about the
procrastination the doubt that first
album bang this one did a billion
streams he was like I'm [ __ ] it
because of the expectation I genuinely I
get it
yeah I can understand yeah but in any
business it's like that yeah it's like
we smashed it and
um
yeah let's do it again yeah it's like do
it again be another one of those when
artists and when people generally make
that move and they and they make they
make their way out to America yeah they
become like
a small fish in a big pond yeah in many
respects like people aren't stopping you
in the street like they are out here oh
that was sick just like I remember going
to the Grammys and I was like standing
next to John Legend and who else was
there there was a massive artists yeah
worldwide success massive records and I
came to stand in and my Publishers put
me in there and the cameraman just that
they were taking John John's down there
uh um what's the Chrissy Chrissy's dad
and then I came in and it was decided
they dropped my cameras and then the guy
was like this
you know when you're talking about
losing
um or not getting the reaction you
wanted it was the best reaction for me I
loved it it was like they don't even
give a [ __ ] I can I can go be that guy
again I can go be the guy
yes there was no expectation so I was in
this environment where there's no
expectation and then it was like now I
can make me now I can go and make who I
am and I was in an environment
on and when I'm talking racially the
reason why I'm talking racially is
because
I felt pulled by these two races in this
country sonically
and and then when I was over there there
was none there was none like lab you
need to be Hood go do another this lab
we need more pop music you need to be a
bit more a regional connect with the
radio more do more Simon Cowell music
um and it was that there was a pull
between me like and I felt like I don't
belong anywhere like because I like both
and I find I can see myself in both but
um there's always somebody that doesn't
like it and that's what um kept on
affecting me was that there's always
someone that doesn't like what I'm doing
and so I kind of became comfortable with
that feeling of being like yes someone's
not gonna like this like and and if
you're a people pleaser that's going to
make you procrastinate yeah yeah 100 but
then I'm like I kind of fell in love
with it in LA where it was just like
that guy doing that was just like I
don't know who this guy is don't care
and then I had to like work on my way up
but in a way that was more pure where it
was like I'm just gonna do what I love
and I was working with people over there
that just kind of like it shed it pulled
away all of the the kind of mess that
that kind of uh created this thing in my
head you know about creativity
and that's like kind of a process of
like reinvention right you're kind of
Reinventing yourself from from again
because the expectation is gone no not
Reinventing
um
realizing realizing because reinvention
is trying to get somewhere realizing
isn't actually going this is who I am
like peel away the onion like
what's underneath and it's like in that
for me that's that's the most important
thing in my career the most important
thing in my existence is to go what's
the rarest form of lab of my person of
my existence what's what's the Roars
form of me even without this body like
what's the soul what's what's my Center
saying what is that
um what do you mean like what is the
center who is lab it was the purest form
if I peel back all those layers on that
onion what is it the core of lab
it's a difficult question one that I'd
struggle to answer no I call it calling
your tears yeah yeah so sometimes
sometimes when I sing
I call this coil in your tears like it's
like I went ahead the [ __ ] scent of
you as well I give you the scent of me
and I want to hear the center of you and
even buy me nuts whatever the [ __ ] is
coming out it's like can I can I can I
speak to you beyond your like oh I have
this thing and I've got money and I
think well who's the guy and I'm like if
I can sing and do this to you and you
see you and you and and we both see uh
uh beyond our flesh beyond the things
that bind us on Earth
um that [ __ ] for me is like that's what
I want to see that's that's what I'm
always trying to get to not not what you
were taught when you were five not my
mask you know I mean not what was was
given to you or you were raised into
like it's like what's what does your
soul want what what is like what's your
soul song as well and so like when I'm
singing I'm like like
for me um
frequency has
is is a language as well like music of
course yeah like hair in a Melody you
can you can hear a feeling from it you
can hear something saying something to
you that's why we listen to music we're
like he speaks to me and I'm like uh
can I speak to you can I can I actually
truthfully speak to you beyond the
[ __ ] and usually frequency
is
one of us like most powerful languages
like literally everything is by by by
vibration like uh
everything on Earth is vibrating that's
that's how like and and that that's how
we can identify a lot of things you can
feel energy if you get me so for me I'm
like
get into the core of that is like the
most exciting thing for me every time I
go into the studio I want to be there
but I'm fighting
uh to
to get away from
needing to police like and and that's
that clouds my mission
all the time
still today yeah 100
Vada
but but it's not as loud as it used to
be
you got music coming out soon yeah what
was what's the process been like making
this this new body of fun yeah it was
fun it was fast
um
I I worked with a band my band LSD me
and Sia and Diplo have a band
and in that in working with CR I kind of
learned how to let go a bit and um when
I went to go wrap my album
after the long album The Long number two
um I just kind of was like yeah let's
just do just do something just do it let
it go don't think about it I did think I
did end up thinking about it like a
little later on because I've had the
album for a while but um
um it was I just was like I enjoy these
Melodies I enjoy what I'm doing I'm
gonna leave it there and I'm
uh alongside Euphoria I was like
um it kind of a lot of these things were
teaching me to do that like come out of
that the pleasing and just go what are
you hearing write what you hear from
this guy and that's it and just leave it
there so that's what I do with this
record as well how much is this record a
reflection of how you're feeling and
where you are in your mind and your
psychology how much of that is reflected
through the music and what you've
created
I believe that this record is one of the
steps towards
um
me being naked like I'm I don't think
I'm as naked as I want to be yet but but
um I I believe that it's getting me
there and like even with this album was
dedicated to my misses
um a lot of the songs on the album were
dedicated to my misses because like I
was talking about where she stood up for
me and supported me
uh through the music through like my
experiences
um uh I kind of wanted to I turned our
relationship in the music industry into
a
um
like two lovers uh Bonnie and Clyde
riding through the the cosmos so so
literally it's like uh Natural Born
Killers in space that's what the whole
album was and that was my like um uh
inspiration for the record is that it's
all love songs but um all of the love
songs are
me taking photos of moments with my with
my wife and things we've been through
together
um and so I didn't even write
I didn't write in it like way where it
was like I'm gonna say oh a couple of
weeks ago on Saturday when this happened
no it's not that it's more it's more
it's more like um Loosely based on on on
like those moments and every song has
like it's me uh
um amplifying like uh like little
moments that me and my wife have had
where'd you get where where sort of
physically do you does MO does your
inspiration show up everything is a song
bro
like everything in here in the streets
in the gym this is a song this is a song
I wait for you this bottle's sitting
here and if you imagine that everything
on Earth is alive this bottle was made
just to sit head to wait to be poured
into my my cup so that's a song I wait
for you I wait for at your Beckham call
whenever you need me and it's like I'm
I'm turning this bottle into a person
and I'm like oh
um
um
don't you know how long I've needed to
be wanted or don't you know I have my
own things or things I want for myself
if you get me so every every like little
thing like um can be like like turned
into or dramatized into a song you know
like
does amazing I'll wait for you
and I'll nutritionally completely
I'll complete you you know like I'm I'm
it's like I'm I'll be your servant it's
like I'm I'm but like when is my moment
like or you can just find things in it
like there's just one thing sitting
there and like start to uh peel the
onion of okay what would it feel like if
I just had to sit there like I was
created and I just had to sit there to
replenish somebody's Health like have
you always thought like that because
that's quite an abstract way to think
like the the metaphor or the symbolism
of what that bottle is doing that a lot
of people would say oh that's a you know
a drink
yeah
um yeah that's everything bro and have
you cultivated yourself to think in such
a way over time where you've lent into
that or is that something that you've
just always had as a no that's that's it
that's it for me like with everything is
like
because I guess um like you're saying
with growing up
um you're going how do people
see the world and you try to see the
world through other people's eyes
especially with when you grow up with
like even traumas or like an intense
home you learn to kind of observe a lot
and so like in observation you go into
like
um storytelling bro like it's like
layers and layers of Storytelling like
um yeah so I just see every every song
even sounds for me have colors sounds
for me have pictures
um so I always have an idea usually what
scares the idea away is people pleasing
honestly like I know I I know what my
idea is but it's like learning how to in
a business
um especially that we go from writing in
our bedrooms to becoming CEOs of
companies without knowing it
um you have to learn how to run your
business and
turn like get your business to
articulate what you want to say without
being frightened of judgment I'm lab
that just got signed to Psycho okay
day one of psycho I get to meet you here
now and I get to come and ask you for
advice I'm I'm you on that day that you
sign with psycho what advice do you give
me
to live your life
whatever it's supposed to be and I don't
I won't take back anything that's
happened honestly like because
um I believe that um everything happens
to build you and I wouldn't have learned
the things I've learned in order to
become who I am today so all my
challenges are turning me into where I'm
supposed to be so do you think if you
told me do you think if you'd given me
advice so I'm you you know when you sign
that deal with psycho do you think if
you'd given me the advice I would have
listened no uh no no no I wouldn't have
listened to me I would have been like
I'll be like yeah man people love my
music let's go like because you just
don't know in it you don't know what
you're going to experience
um yes I would I would I would say go
and experience what you need to
experience because like you're gonna
head
to your
to your North in whatever way you can
and some people don't ever find their
North because they don't learn to go
okay
um let me take a look at myself you know
like I think that's the my dad did that
the way he just he wasn't able to be
vulnerable enough to go okay maybe this
or maybe like could I change this or
actually I'm not happy here you know
um
um and so I feel like if you can do that
in your life
um I don't think anything's wrong with
it I think
um you you'll be able to find your North
like by by being able to observe
yourself
what are your goals now
I imagine to make the cosmic Opera
okay bro it's mad no tell me that's your
God I want to hear it oh yeah yeah I do
I want to make an opera you want to make
an opera yeah yeah I want to write an
opera can hear the sounds it can hear
how it looks feels
um
and
um
yeah just I wanna
I wanna like make
um
like uh I want to do things with choirs
that nobody's done I can hear all these
things that I'm like nobody's done this
I'm gonna go do it like literally I'm
there do you know we did this podcast
live with a live Gospel Choir taught up
in another country oh really yeah yeah
and it's this mixture between like the
visual so the video would come in and it
would like crackle from people on this
podcast yeah and then you'd have me with
spoken words and then the choir would
come in and like say the message in
music if that makes sense yeah yeah so I
might be talking about the struggle I
had with like um that the one's
self-doubt and then the other young
ambitious kid that knew he wanted to be
a millionaire yeah because he was
insecure whatever yeah and on one hand
you've got wait till I get my money and
you've got Gnarls Barkley I think you're
crazy and it was that kind of like that
perfect like music and stuff yeah bro
you're doing it man that's exactly all
of it yeah but it is for me you get
afraid now
afraid of I'm just saying oh yeah do you
feel do do you feel maybe used to your
fears no so like stepping out on stage
at the London Palladium yeah we opened
up at the London Palladium and stepping
out on stage at London Palladium never
having done this before in front of
people and knowing that they'd bought
tickets without having any idea what
they brought tickets to they're
expecting a live podcast so they're
expecting this on stage okay and then
there's quite and you know there was a
moment of that where you've just got to
be at peace with the uncertainty okay
yeah and all the great things come from
being at peace with the uncertainty yeah
you know which is do you feel like maybe
your piece with the uncertainty comes
from your parents
um yes so I would say my parents were so
absent from my life like my mum and dad
were like my mum was never in when I got
home she was never when I woke up so I
got to play yeah kind of experiment if
you know what I mean definitely so much
so you start building evidence in
yourself like well I try this thing and
it kind of works yes yeah I kind of
never unlearned that lesson you never
once you've seen behind that curtain
that you can just try stuff and yes and
are you okay with the um like if it
bombed would you be okay
the honest answer yeah so if it bombed
bombed yeah no because
it's crazy because like I remember I
remember you know the feedback we got is
like nothing I've ever got my career you
get that one message yeah yeah yeah that
was [ __ ] weird and I'm thinking about
it the next night before I go out I'm
thinking that one person said it was
[ __ ] weird yeah yeah I feel you I
feel even though
everyone's listening brilliant I loved
it yeah you're just like that one guy
yeah I feel you because a search for
validation can be a real motivator in
your life it can force you to like go
out there and do great stuff yeah but at
the same time it also makes you really
susceptible to criticism yeah yeah no it
does it drives you but it makes it
scares you know it's like but if you
like that's what I love about hip-hop I
was watching um hip-hop Evolution and
loads of the guys on there they kind of
were just like we're already the
scumbags of the earth to this country
like there's nothing to lose yeah and I
kind of when I watch it I'm just like I
love to like to just they just go and do
anything because it was just like well
we're like I have one out on record on
the album called only way is up here
yeah and I I say
um the only way is up um what's it it
was like um basically like yeah the only
way is up like it's like we literally
if you're at the pit of of the bottoms
like there's nothing else to do so it's
just that they were just like I'm going
for I'm I'm taking it all and that's
where hip-hop turned into well it's like
a massive industry now like and it
wasn't it started from a guy just being
on like 10 on 10 turntables you know so
um when you sometimes I get inspired by
seeing that when your next project comes
out say every song in the album gets a
trillion views it's the first album ever
to get a trillion views on every record
right next time you see me I'm going to
be like yeah what's going on
why are you speaking like that yeah no
what do you mean
just with glasses
lab doesn't want to talk right now
why are you speaking about yourself in
the first person are you scared of that
what I'm becoming a [ __ ]
but like
anything if you're next up you get a
trillion views on every record Here
Comes expectation again suddenly you've
got something to lose again
now I burn it down every time
just burn down the house like uh and
it's so beautiful to like
to be free of expectation of your own
and of of your own expectation as well
for me it's like you're like Forrest
Gump man you could do anything like with
that when you're free from and free uh
funny my son this is his favorite song
right now free from design man um but
anyway but when you are free from desire
in terms of like the need for an like a
reception or the need for validation
it's like if you actually put that down
if you said I don't need validation
you're like you're just gonna go do
anything bro like you just go ham you
know and some people are born like kind
of have that like it's just in them
where they're just like well maybe
they're scared but they they don't show
it and they're just able to just move on
really fast and they have insane
resilience and I'm like
if I had that
um
like what would I have done what would I
have done and I'm not a person to go
back to the past but but I'm like like
how free would it be and how freeing
would it be if you could just go
cool that didn't work let's go like and
not even that didn't work just I'm gonna
do what I'm here to do which is make
music do you see any of your peers or
anyone in the industry it's funny I was
thinking of Kanye West I mean a
controversial figure yeah yeah he seems
to not give a [ __ ] about he really
doesn't I've worked with him yeah yeah
he's um and it was inspiring and that's
you're not even with Kanye
his mad controversial mad is is yeah
it's a lot but
um
I guess he's intense for the world but
being in his creative environment was
one of the most inspiring
um I've had and I wasn't a Kanye fan
like I wasn't like oh I've listened to
all your albums I know every song like I
literally was put with his current with
Kanye through a manager and they were
like Labs [ __ ] next hot hot as
artists do you want to work with him and
then I got a yes and then I went into
the camp so I started working with all
these amazing musicians and producers
and it was just like it feels like what
I love which is
uh hear it do it uh um it's got no
nothing on the periphery affects the the
the the division of what what is had
what he's headed for especially in that
environment sometimes maybe I don't know
he personally when he's at home on his
own uh it's affected by but it was just
the vibe in there was just like it felt
like true creativity
um but like I can't say anything about
yeah like I don't know what mission is
on like yeah I was thinking of us had
Dame Dash here like a week ago and
dating said Jay-Z is all about the money
Kanye is all about the art yeah and that
seems to be what's reflected from what
you see on from the outside yeah that
makes sense yeah yeah going back so I
asked you a question about your goal
yeah and you said about the cosmic
Orchestra yeah
that that's a that's I guess that's a
goal is there like a bigger a mission
you're on or is it I I think I've
simplified my desires and it's like I
just want to be a tap
I want to be a tap and it sounds very um
it sounds very um
wispy but like to be a tap for the
universe and what I mean by the universe
is that I I personally believe that we
are all connected to a a source and
um
if we're all connected to that source
everyone has their everyone's a
kaleidoscope and when this Source shines
through our kaleidoscopes you see these
unique beautiful things as but but we
have to make our Kaleidoscope as pure as
possible meaning to get out of our own
ways to be the Kaleidoscope That was
supposed to be and for me I feel like
I'm seeing some of your kaleidoscope and
and you made the decision to change your
world or to change your maybe facade
that you had at the time to become who
you who you need to be and you click
clean the window you know and so for me
I'm like if I can clean my window and
and shine light as purely as possible
and do some [ __ ] that I didn't even know
I could do for me that's a job well done
honestly like in all truth but the only
thing that gets in the way is fair
self-doubt and all the all the stuff
that like the industry needing to make
money like needed to be validated gets
in the way of like oh [ __ ] I'm supposed
to be cleaning the window like um that's
what I keep doing I'll keep going back
to like oh okay sorry I forgot
can I clean my so that's what I want to
do clean windows
it's a really interesting analogy yeah
the most authentic self and yeah that's
it for me but it's it's it's easier said
than done we're always saying it online
and I want to speak my truth I'm like
that stuff doesn't mean anything to me
it's just to to to purely and you know
when you're lying to yourself the only
person that knows you're lying to you is
you like and and sometimes you don't
know when you're lying to yourself if
you're not looking properly but when you
look when you truly look you're like
okay I'm lying and so for me cleaning
the window is knowing when I'm lying
and then being like okay cool let's go
we're going back to truth yes let's do
it I mean
much of the reason why I you know I've
always resonated with your music and I
view it as art you know even I was
listening to it all again today yeah
going through the albums going through
some of your new stuff yeah is because
you have that it's it's so clearly comes
from it feels like it comes from a very
authentic Place yeah like you're not
I've not heard these sounds before yeah
you know what I mean even when I go to
when I listen to pass out again there's
so many layers to this that like there's
some like
get garagey grimy stuff and then you've
got the little afro you know it's all
yeah it's all in there yeah yeah and
this is something that's how I you know
when you ask me what happens when I
listen back I'm like oh is that how I
look it's like you're like oh like
because there's self-doubt it's so heavy
sometimes that you don't even know how
you look and it's like somebody could be
like you're so beautiful and you're like
I'm seeing warts I'm seeing weird [ __ ]
and then you you your idea of yourself
is so distorted so when I listen back to
old stuff sometimes I'm like it's like
music just like Well Done kids I'm like
man like it feels feels like you're
you've got your own identity and I'm
like I I almost end up saying to that 24
year old like I'm like bro I'm proud of
you like like that's so fun like I I
feel you like and I didn't at the time
at the time I was like I don't know what
I'm doing you know
so it's nice to kind of observe from a
distance and be like grandfather going
well done
are you happy now am I happy now
um yes I I definitely have you as a
father
that changes your life massively
um so I think
um
um yeah I think I'm super happy
um
yeah like like I I I I like to think
about that when someone asks me yeah
because that's easy yeah how are you
yeah yeah I'm great yeah
it's a difficult and some people think
it's a shitty question because first
you've got to Define what happy Means
and happy is a mood yeah it's like you
know I'm sad happy it's it's a kind of a
visceral maybe you should ask me on my
content yeah I know I'm fulfilled or
something yeah yeah I'm content I think
with fulfillment I'm I'm getting there
no I'm
I'm I'm cleaning the window all the time
so it's like realizing it's returning
back to fulfillment if that makes sense
if so if that fulfillment was a recipe
consisting of different ingredients in
different quantities yeah right so you
need one egg if you have two eggs the
recipe goes off it's all about you know
with recipes it's all about balance and
constructing the ingredients you need to
create the perfect
dish if your fulfillment is a recipe
list
is there anything missing off that that
you believe now would make you would
make that recipe perfect for me it's
been balanced it's just workaholic
that's kind of like an addiction that I
have yes because of early stuff yep same
yeah so trying to make sure I'm
investing in my romantic relationships
my friendships for real so I can feel it
same with my kids and my family like
yeah that balance but fulfillment is for
me is
um
Desiring nothing contributing everything
that's how I feel like and it's like and
and maybe the only one desire is to to
remain
um
present enough to be able to receive uh
from what I'm contributing to does that
make sense perfect sense yeah or else
you're not going to be there to hear it
I won't even enjoy it I won't even yeah
my kid would be smiling at me and I'm
like looking over onto the heads like
yeah how do I get more how do I get a
truly abuse
being present to experience the joy of
life well it's the best when you're
present with your kids it's the best
like you learn so much stuff my kids
said like she loves the moon and um she
asked me does moonstones fall from the
Moon and I and she said they give me um
the moon gives me moonstones all the
time and she's like um and shall we give
them back and I was like I was like no
no I think it was given to you as a
present but just like hearing stuff like
that for me is like it's like magic like
it's just hearing a magical mind's day
and it's like I'm still uh
um appreciating the world in this
magical way when when we make it about a
trillion views you know like same with
my son as well just he smells flowers
and like
he he really like he if he sees a flower
he points at and he wants to
really feel it and connect with it and
and enjoy it and then he will go around
giving everyone a flower and saying
smell it for yourself but seeing that
for me is like he made something that
um got like um I ignore because I'm just
so used to it it's like super magical
um
yeah beautiful and it's yeah I was
thinking about my dog there as well how
he simplified my life just like I used
to say like come I'd come home from like
the busy day all these problems and the
dog is there just [ __ ] around with
this Lucas a bottle yep having the time
of his life
I'm like you don't understand how simple
yeah it's for fact I've over complicated
how simple and wonderful it is yeah but
I've lost sight of that with my
with my wisdom or with my experience
yeah we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the last guest asks a
question for the next guest they don't
know who they're asking it for okay they
just write it in this diary
this guest is handwriting challenged so
give me a second
my teacher used to call it chicken
scratches oh it looks it looks a bit
this looks like chicken scratches okay
what
are you not saying yes to in your life
that demands to be said
well am I not saying yes to that demands
to be said
yeah I think I think what they mean is
like what are you not saying yes to that
demands yes uh yes yeah yeah um
nothing
saying yes to all the stuff I want to
say yes to
right
is there anything inside you that's
that's asking you to like step into it
and accept it that you're not saying yes
to okay uh no no okay so if we're going
from there
um uh
um
I think except in what is
um and uh yeah just accepting what is
like not getting um dragged into
uh
what it could be
and when you accept what it is you're
like this is sick like you just fall in
love with it because you're appreciating
it for what it is you know so I think
it's that constantly we're remembering
that but that's that's a yes for the
rest of your life
um thank you so much for this
conversation thank you for being here I
you are a musical genius I respect bro I
appreciate it no you are because because
I can't really think of artists and that
have come out of the UK I've come out
[ __ ] Hackney that have the like the
creative diversity
that you have we don't have like
honestly the only other person I think
of is I'm like Kanye you know I'm about
yeah you know yeah yeah I feel yeah well
I I believe you could I believe with
that sort of creative palette and the
diversity of your creativity and where
you see inspiration in a [ __ ] huel
bottle which is nutritionally complete
hashtag ad in the table
um is really genius it's a real special
genius and with that comes a lot of
challenge as we see with Kanye as well
but yeah but it's a real special genius
that I think as you say if the windows
can remain clean bro that's it for me
it's gonna serve the world in a
remarkable way as it has done already
for you in your life and you know the
things you've done with movies the music
and you talk to me about this Opera I
better see and believe it all and I go
oh man I gotta come yeah when one once I
got it somewhere you've got to come and
listen please
the worst music
listen I'll clean the windows I don't
care let me I'll help you clean the
windows so we can get this Cosmic
Orchestra going oh man I'm down I'm down
I would love for you to hear it but
um yeah like um that's I'm definitely
excited about this I appreciate you so
it's nice to meet you and I can't wait
to see this next project and all the
projects that you bring to bring to the
world um in the future thank you so much
thanks
quick one from our longest standing
sponsor hero for many years people have
been asking for a coffee flavored Hill
and quite recently he'll release the
iced coffee caramel flavor of their
um ready to drink heels and I've just
become hooked on it over the last couple
of weeks I've been on a really
interesting Journey with huel which I've
described and talked about a little bit
on this podcast I started with the berry
ready to drinks then I moved over to the
protein salted caramel because it's 100
calories and it gives you all of your
essential vitamins and minerals but also
gives you the 20 odd grams of protein
you need and now I'm balanced between
them both I drink mostly the banana
flavor ready to drink I've got really
into the iced coffee caramel flavor of
Jules ready to drink and now I'm
drinking that as well as the protein
make sure you try the new ready to drink
flavors that the caramel flavor is
amazing the new banana flavor as well is
amazing and obviously as I said the iced
coffee caramel flavor has been a real
Smash Hit so check it out let me know
what you think on social media I see all
of your tags and Instagram posts and
tweets about you
[Music]
know